[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSE WILSON: Cash App is
the fastest and easiest
way to send money.
You get a personalized debit
card with great rewards,
and you can buy
and sell bitcoin.
So we launched in the
Play Store in 2013.
And, as of December, we had
15 million active users.
In 2015, one of my co-workers
wrote this document
using Project Kotlin
in Android, and it got
us all really excited about it.
Ever since Android Studio
and the Android team
have embraced Kotlin, things
have gotten even better.
Whenever we want to
change a new feature,
we always convert
it to Kotlin first.
One of the things I really
like about Kotlin is lambdas.
It really makes programming with
RxJava very easy and fluent.
And it was something
that allowed
us to take two different
technologies that we really
liked and use them together.
With Kotlin, we're able to
eliminate many builders,
and we're able to
really cut down
on the amount of code we write.
In some cases, we
save 25% of our code.
I really like Kotlin's
fantastic deprecation features.
It allows us to evolve our API
as our business problems change
and quickly update
all the call sites.
We're constantly improving
our business model
and solving more problems.
And with that, we need to
migrate new code to the latest
model.
[INAUDIBLE] makes that
very fast and easy.
One of the features we're
really excited about
is Kotlin Multiplatform.
It's going to give our
Android developers the ability
to ship code onto iOS and our
iOS developers the ability
to ship code onto Android.
With sealed classes, we
can create loading, error,
and content screens all
in a single sealed type,
and this allows us to move
faster to make changes
and to really understand
our data model
in a stronger-type, safe way.
On Cash, we ship the
app every two weeks.
With Kotlin, we're able to
get more code with higher
quality in every release.
I think it's time to dive in.
I think Kotlin is ready, and
I think that when you use it,
you'll see just how
much it transforms
how you think about your code.
[MUSIC PLAYING]